two different cable networks today MSNBC
and seeing them at different points in
the day we're raising serious questions
I mean these are big big leagues
reporters about the mental state of
President Trump implying or not just
coming up like saying that he looks like
he has early onset dementia he's
unstable
he's destructive he's an imbalanced at a
time where we could very well be facing
a war with North Korea you've had a lot
of interactions with the president tell
us about what you view his intellectual
mental capacity those accusations are
absolutely outrageous I mean I speak to
the president of virtually daily basis
and I'm involved with him all the time
on all these issues and that kind of
accusation is totally baseless and
outrageous I mean it's so personal and
it's someone who my father had dementia
and it's personal to me and yet these
charges are being thrown around a lot of
people believe as a precursor to perhaps
a Democrat takeover into it 2018 and
then ultimately a push to try to remove
him from office that feeling is in this
building the Democrats want want to
invalidate this election one way or
another look I think those kind of
accusations are completely off-base and
irresponsible let's argue over the
issues we have different points of view
for example the decision to get on the
tax bill was totally partisan every
Democrat said I don't want to do tax
reform every Republican said I do that's
the appropriate area for us to have our
discussions in public about the future
of the country